605 on your wet Monday morning all right
I-15 back open between Russell Road and
Flamingo part of the ndot Tropicana
project but our Candace Charles is live
near trop and Dean Martin with a look at
how Tropicana is definitely different
now that it's back open can you explain
that for us there Candace
good morning good morning folks yes we
are experiencing something that may be a
little confusing I'm excited to report
though that the 15 is Flowing nicely
this morning what may be confusing as
Nate mentioned is on Tropicana this
diverging diamond here now it's supposed
to help the hectic traffic that's
expected to come as a section of the
I-15 reopened today but traffic will be
down to two lanes in each Direction so
at the side dredging Diamond traffic is
briefly rotted to the upper opposite
side of the road allowing cars to turn a
left on freeway on ramps without
stopping or crossing traffic so that
should make things a little bit easier
now this is similar to The Interchange
of Horizon Drive Interstate 11 in
Henderson again this is the third of
three phases in that's huge Tropicana
Tropicana project we've been telling you
guys about the state intends to upgrade
the I-15 Tropicana interchange and
Tropicana Avenue Bridge over live 15
over the next few years I'm adding an
extra Lane on Tropicana pedestrian
upgrades like walkways and Lighting near
the bridge now you can see some of the
guys out here already starting to do
more work on that and we'll continue to
see more developments as this is a
multi-year project and of course we'll
be with you along the way now if any of
this is confusing don't worry folks
there is an app for that I have the I-15
a trump app or you can just go to
i15trop.com to see all the visuals you
may need now it's suggested that you
also use the Waze app and that has
partnered with them to make sure that
they have all your detours for you on
there as well and of course as always we
have you covered with the details stick
with us right here on there online and
on social for the latest you can go to
our website newsnow.com for now live
from the town suites off of Tropicana
and Dean Martin I'm Candace Charles 8
News Now